let's go back in time
[Music]
this was the future of cars in 1981 and
when the DeLorean dmc-12 to gain
production with Goldwing doors going as
in gulls gull wing doors doors in
unpainted stainless steel panels because
paint is for cars that could never
convincingly play a time machine the
future looked pretty great from every
angle and then on October 19th 1982 that
timeline ended got a spoiler this is not
a DeLorean
so like a lot of people I first heard
about the DeLorean from Back to the
Future and this fictional version of the
car was wildly popular but then you find
out that the real DeLorean fail less
than two years after production began
how does that happen
somehow it is still such a popular car
that DeLorean clubs meet around the
world just to talk about how great it is
have a green light
the DeLorean story goes from hill valley
in 1955 to margaret thatcher's
Parliament to war-torn Belfast Ireland
to a very rainy parking lot near
Washington DC
that story goes a ton of places even
where I'm driving right now in this
resoundingly mediocre vehicle when you
get into this story it turns out that
the DeLorean really is a time machine
[Music]
right now I am in it right now let me um
let me see if I can flip the camera
around right I can do that right this
entire car is 100% original
I like the DMC logo up there that's
that's one thing that's unique the the
door ajar light you know has the gold
wing the DeLoreans many quirks are a
collection of design choices and
manufacturing irregularities legendary
Italian designer Giorgetto Giugiaro
created the design in 1974 and refined
it through 1978 early brainstorms for a
mid-engine became a rear engine and the
stainless panels were smoothed out of it
Lotus via legendary racer and engineer
Colin Chapman provided the cars
engineering the engine was a Renault v6
the gullwing doors were in the legacy of
cars like the Bricklin a failed Goldwyn
Indy car as well as gold wings by
Mercedes those golden doors required
unusual adaptations like a cryogenically
twisted torsion bar in tiny windows
called Tollbooth windows because they
were just large enough to pay a toll but
it actually wasn't hard to get in and
out of those gold wing door anybody
watching this can go see it on my
youtube channel it's just geek therapy
radio in the myth is that going doors
you can't park in any parking lot
because if someone parks too close to
you you're trapped doors as you see
hinge in the roof so the doors go up
more than they go out
[Music]
DeLorean fans are always debating about
the cars quality if you say that the
engine is underpowered they'll tell you
well it wasn't that underpowered for
cars at the time if you say that the
DeLorean was heavy they'll say oh well
look at these Porsches they were
actually heavier or the same way so the
arguing it is a rite of passage if
you're a DeLorean every time I see
someone posts a picture of a DeLorean on
Reddit you go into the comments and it's
usually people posting this information
other people are ragging on the car for
whatever reason and then of course you
get like one or two people usually
sometimes maybe we're gonna then start
attacking going no here's the real
history and it's like we're arguing on
the Internet
who cares right but it's ready
you like the car you like the car you
don't like the car you don't like the
car BFT so whatever you think of the car
the DeLoreans design was improbably
but its creation that that was almost
impossible
I remember having a conversation with
John once when we were walking around
the club I said to him you know what is
it about the car John that is sacrosanct
to you did one of three things stainless
steel going doors
rear engine you could do it your life of
anything else
the Oh mines Barry wills I was actually
the first employee hired out of the UK
power industry into DeLorean I read
about John Ross he boozed charisma he
was charming he was smart and above all
he demonstrated a thorough knowledge of
the auto industry we are here
[Music]
it's a liquor store cutty sark whiskey
the whiskey with a boat I have this
whiskey because John Z DeLorean in his
car were used in this ad to help sell it
who's that glamorous already John
DeLorean was a superstar he started as
an engineer this 1958 patent one of many
was for a slick drive transmission that
he designed but he found bigger roles in
1964 he was considered instrumental in
creating the pontiac gto the car was
young and cool it remade Pontiacs
reputation and made a reputation for
John DeLorean and by the 1970s he was in
line to be president of General Motors
being president of GM at that time was
like being next in line to be king
here's a bummer but DeLorean was chafing
at it he thought it was too corrupt and
he thought they were too square he was a
celebrity and was a rebel so he quit but
he had stayed long enough to make a
reputation for himself
[Music]
this is him in 1974 a year after he quit
GM critics of course said that he was
fired long hair cool shirt
a new look he said he had surgery due to
either an injury or a jaw bone impact
correction critics said it was a
makeover the same way he made over
Pontiac he also married his third wife
the internationally famous Christina
Ferrara who he said he'd literally first
seen in the pages of Vogue he was the
celebrity maverick who fired GM and that
gave him the mystique to take them all
I hope you're enjoying that authentic
turn-signal sound I've actually composed
a song for later in this video when we
hit our deepest emotional gap it's a sad
song I'm going to play it later the new
DeLorean Motor Company had glamorous
investors like the tonight shows Johnny
Carson as well as a unique plan to get
investments from car dealers the
presentation of the DeLorean Motor
Company our requirements are one the
dealer or his dealer associates must own
$25,000 in DeLorean Motor Company
Commons dark
but a brand-new factory and car required
north of a hundred million in investment
them in government cash there were a few
potential timelines early flirtations
with a Saudi Arabian investor in the
state of Pennsylvania fizzled a plan
with Puerto Rico got further offering a
package close to sixty million if
DeLorean raised 25 million first and
spent at first but Northern Ireland and
therefore the UK eventually paid up
around 120 million dollars depending how
you split loans grants and guarantees
the location of the factory it's
difficult you want 72 acres of well who
are capitalized there's half a mountain
have to be relocated from outside
Belfast to put enough footings onto the
site to construct the building you know
put the steel framework up in fact with
the two streams have to be dug dirty
this was with an insanely fast 18 month
timeframe and an even more unstable
political environment all this was
during the Troubles the violent
sectarian conflict in which Northern
Ireland was fighting over whether they
should be part of the Republic of
Ireland or the UK and this is why
DeLorean got the money the British
government wanted to add stability and
jobs to a violent unemployment plagued
region Barry wills says that it actually
didn't impact production that much but
riots did spill into the factory and
they had to consider stuff like hunger
strikes into their production timeline
as each hunger strike had died the
Catholic Republican workforce will be
called out for a day of mourning the
director of personnel was given a
program by the Northern Ireland office
of the likely death days of the hunger
strikers so that we could plan ahead a
terrible
[Music]
any other company would have let off the
gas in this situation but DeLorean did
not have a choice
there should be 1,800 cars in October of
1981
they had to keep up with their funding
applications hire large workforce pay
bonuses make royalty payments it was a
lot they pulled it all off really
quickly this DeLorean Motor Company
infomercial shows the factory of work
but they needed constant cash to keep
this going from car sales or the British
government they needed perfection but
they got reality instead though the
company had turned a slight profit by
some measures there were also almost
5,000 unsold cars by January of 1982
they were very pricey at $25,000 and
they've gotten a bad reputation a 2000
cart recall and performance issues in
the first batch didn't help the first
cars were shipped out states were not
good cars
we were under immense pressure the
government made it clear that we weren't
gonna get any more money by February
1982 DMC was in receivership basically a
forced bankruptcy by May production
stopped DeLorean had dipped back for
money before in the UK led by
conservative Margaret Thatcher didn't
want to give more money to an American
company rumors and fishy corporate
structures credible accusations of fraud
and possible millions in diverted money
didn't help make the sale
so all that had to have made it harder
to raise cash in those last-ditch
efforts now DeLorean fans they will tell
you that the company failed because of
the recession and bad weather and
exchange rates and never really good
point
all that stuff did hurt the company but
it might not have doomed the company had
had not taken on so much risk again and
again all those bets
well eventually DeLorean was going to
lose
and that was all before the flashiest
scandal of all happened
[Music]
in autumn DeLorean was arrested for
trying to raise money in an unusual way
agreeing to smuggle millions of dollars
worth of cocaine it was horrific you
know I was told the night before that we
all believed that John was raising the
money there where he was coming from I
got a call evening would be four hours
before John's arrest to say bring the
work off together tomorrow I'm sorry
Barry it's all with the liquidation
DeLorean was eventually acquitted
because of entrapment he was never
convicted of smuggling or a fraud so you
have to make a judgment call when you
see this man do you see a genius or an
actor playing a part
maybe he was both John Z DeLorean
why did your car have to die but your
dream lives on let me show you
all right so if you don't know what Big
Lots is it got its start as an overstock
store a bargain bin place and when
DeLorean went bankrupt the parent
company of Big Lots actually bought all
the DeLorean parts talking like the
stainless steel panels and all those
parts went into a warehouse it looked
like the end of the DeLorean story and
then a movie came out what is the
comment that you get over and over again
this is what makes time travel possible
after the movie it's all about the
capacitor capacitor where's the flux
capacitor you know after a while you
just get worn down and you have to make
it like a surface capacitor capacitor
back to the future but usually it's the
McFly the condom movie it was a fantasy
it had to go 88 miles to travel in time
and the original DeLorean speedometer
doesn't even go that high
they had to modify for the movie but
little differences like that didn't stop
the DeLorean from becoming the time
machine after the movie two communities
developed in the vacuum left by DeLorean
Motor Company's failure today there's a
strong international roster of companies
able to service DeLoreans and supply
factory original parts even though they
weren't a part of the original company
and there are also clubs around the
world where owners can support each
other we have about 80 members in the
club right now we do events four times a
year one of Tiffany's first events was a
DeLorean mid-atlantic pilgrimage to John
Z DeLorean smashing the club events
aren't just about the past they've made
the car a platform for creativity it's a
stainless steel Lego set everybody has
their level modifications they like from
my own car I've actually done custom
repulsor seats I've upgraded the exhaust
to stainless steel exhaust that's been
from DeLorean go and Europe it sounds
great
[Music]
so at this point I've done fuel lines
the alternator fuses and relays radiator
fans the entire suspension at this point
has been upgraded parsing lowered
new tires we will share parts with each
other like if someone's working on
something and we need something like I
have extra worn parts so it's kind of
neat knowing that you have part of your
car of someone else's living on I I made
it and did all the programming and that
developed all the software and put it in
my car this is this runs everything on
the car it gets data to the digital dash
I mean as most owners will tell you it's
never
yeah well I of course had to upgrade
that that's Lightning McQueen and he's
in for an overhaul III doubled the
voltage on it that'll be ready for the
springs
there's one clip in particular I really
like it's of the tristate DeLorean Club
and they are taking a club picture with
all their cars now look at them look how
they rush to get out of the way they are
happy to give up the spotlight in a way
that John Z DeLorean never could this
car succeeded because it inspired people
let's in this video in the right car and
all those people there the thing that
brings us together is this car but
they're all really great people in there
they're you know it gets normal friends
and it's it's a good thing I've reached
the point in my life now where I have to
really choose where I'm going to spend
my time and the type of people I'm gonna
be around
gotta be really careful before you spend
your time you know always
[Music]
so thank you for riding with me today if
you want to check out a cars and coffee
like the one that I went to in the video
there might be one in your area there's
a lot of really cool cars that people
share there thank you also to the
tri-state DeLorean club for letting me
tag along they were all awesome and
incredibly nice thank you to berry
Will's for sharing with me his stories
they are detailed further in his book
about his career with DeLorean finally
in our membership program the video lab
I am reviewing five or six of the top
DeLorean books which I read for this
piece and letting you know which ones
you should check out and which ones you
can go ahead and skip